hey y'all it's sandy couch here in this
tight tuesday video we're gonna be uh
using some tidy models but to do a
little change up we're gonna do some
business applications
so uh when i was in college um in
business school
uh we actually had a few machine
learning classes however we didn't
really focus too much
on the actual algorithms and
understanding the
entire logic so you know we would go
through like
decision trees and on some methods but
we wouldn't really go over the actual
frameworks of it
um but what we actually focused mostly
on was
um figuring out how to assign value and
use these models
in a business so i thought it'd be kind
of interesting to use the tidy models
package create a model on a customer
churn set
and then create define a custom metric
which in this case
what we're going to try to do is assign
profit so
when you're trying to predict whether
customer will trend or not um there
might be a value if you
successfully predict that a potential
customer will churn so you'll save money
or
save money or increase our revenue or if
we falsely
unpredict or we already miss a turned
customer then we'll lose money
so i think this would be an interesting
um
segment especially since it'll basically
force us to do some custom metrics
because uh we can do this in r in
business school we actually did a lot of
it in excel so we would make the models
in r and then output the test sets
probabilities and then do it in excel
and
figure out some profit curves from that
but since we're you know in the tidy
verse we can definitely do it using
yardstick
before i actually jump into the code i
will say i have a link for
a q a video so you can submit your
questions for my
one year anniversary uh and i'm pretty
excited for that so
hopefully you guys can send me some
questions i have a decent amount so far
but
if you have any questions please let me
know in the description below
i'm going to open up a arm our markdown
document it calls tidy
tuesday applied
business cool
i'm going to full screen this okay so
now what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna load
in the
id first
um id models
and then i'm gonna also load in um
themis
and then the dataset which will be a
customer
churn.csv so we've already gone over
this dataset
which is why i knew that i needed themis
because if we look at it
we can do a count of churn
and we can see that only a thou only
about 2
000 of the 7000 samples uh
have an actual churn okay which makes
sense uh if we're gonna have a data set
or have a bunch of customers we would
expect that it wouldn't be even for turn
right most of them
won't churn um if if it is even we have
a balanced data return
uh we would probably have to reevaluate
our business models
okay so we have that um we also can do a
basic summary
and see all the nas and if you think
there's about one there's about 11
n a's we can do we can just drop that so
i'm going to do a drop n a additionally
i'm going to mutate
in your citizen it's equal to as dot
factor citizen
make sure to count that just see if
there's no
thing so zero or one so zero i'm
assuming is not being a senior assistant
and one being a senior citizen
okay um and then yeah that's that's
basically it
we have to really worry about so we'll
do most of our stuff
in uh
uh in the pre-processing so let's do the
pre-processing
first we have to create our training
test sets i'm gonna go pretty fast with
the modeling because
uh the main focus of this video isn't
really the modeling
um we're just going to make an xg boost
model tune it
uh fit it and then do the actual custom
metrics so
let's do that first so um i'll create
create
train and test splits um
tidy we'll do a set seed 42
tidy split initial split
idea prop is equal to point eight we'll
also stratify
oops rata is equal to uh churn
how do you train we'll be uh training
ready
split and then tidy test
and then we'll do our k folds data k
folds
we'll say tidy a fold
and for our k-folds we're going to be
using our training
data set cool
now we're going to do our pre-processing
so
with our recipe we're going to give it
turn
data equals tidy ring
i actually want to see if our turn
is up so i'm going to actually mutate
i'll say mutate
if is that character
as that factor
so now we have all that stuff okay
okay so now what i want to do first is
remove
the um the customer id because we know
that
that's not going to be informative um
i'm also going to do a box cox
transformation on the
numeric values i'll do also minus all
outcomes uh i'm using box [ __ ] because
our actual numerical values which is
monthly charges and
total charges i'm assuming are not
negative
so that way we can actually use box cogs
instead of like the eo johnson
uh yeah so we have that um also do a
step of normalize which will be all
numeric minus all outcomes
and then what i'll also do is step
i'll do a step other which will be all
nominal minus all outcomes
this is basically to remove any um
features that have a high amount of
uh levels or a large amount of levels
which i don't think we actually do
so and i'm looking at it no i'm fine
with that
we not to do that and then i'll just do
step
uh dummy all nominal
minus all outcomes
i'll also say one hot is equal to true
right so we have that and i'll say tidy
wreck i'm just going to do a sanity
check just to see if it works
and your monthly charges turn is still
there we have our male female
citizen
um let's see here contract okay that
makes sense
okay sweet so all this makes sense i'm
fine with that
so now let's actually have our model so
we'll just do an xgboost
model boost tree um in this case we'll
adjust our
trees and our tree
uh depth
ooh actually i forgot to do a step
um let's see uh
uh we'll say down sample and this will
be
the uh turn
because with our turn data sets um
we kind of want to make it even just for
our model in this case it did that
i believe so if we count
that we have about even even stevens
cool
okay um we're gonna set our
model to classification if i yep and
then we'll say
set engine to
engine to actually boost and we'll say
actually boost grid
ready to regular actually using the
parameters from the actually boost
model we'll say uh
five right now
um and then also i'll say filter
is equal to c trees is greater than one
cool actually i might just change that
to
now i'm fine with that i'm fine with
that okay cool
so we have that um
we'll also do our i guess model control
so actually we'll do our ooh
i totally forgot one thing so with our
data set right now
um if we actually look at the levels so
if we say
uh df uh turn
and we check the levels of it
oh then we have to do as dot
factor we check the levels of it it's
gonna count
not churning as being a positive class
in that case we actually don't
want that so what we can actually do is
say we can say mutate
churn it's equal to asset
uh reverse and we'll give it that
cool that way now we can do levels
ef churn and we have the first thing
which is yes
is uh with tidying models it uses the
first level as the positive class
so that'll do that you can do this again
you should really change okay
cool so now we have that let's set our
um
model metrics so model
metrics metric set let's say uh rdc aoc
um accuracy and we'll also do mean log
boss and now let's actually tune our
uh our model so actually boost
tune grid
we'll give it our model
our recipe
our grid which will be our actually
boost
grid our resamples would be our
tidy k folds and then we'll also give it
our metrics
which is our model metrics
okay we have that going
um now what i'm actually going to do is
i'm going to look at the custom metrics
hopefully okay so with the model with
the custom metrics
um there are a few ways to do this um
what i'm going to do is i'm going to do
the data frame input like implementation
um you can do as a vector where you can
just like pass on a list of
you know predictions and a list of uh
of true values or you can kind of do
where
you know it's it's nice as like almost a
function
and deal with that so what i'm going to
do is just copy
the data frame implementation right here
so if we actually go back up let me see
we're at
um yeah right here we can basically just
copy all this actually i think we can
copy right
there and i can just put in
that
um okay and then what we can also do is
i think this is the
vector
and then we can copy that
and put this in there
yep okay so this is just like an example
of doing miss rate
um that's fine what i'm actually gonna
call this is i'm gonna say
like s like profit
s okay
so profit estimation um and we got
we'll just change all this so we'll see
yes
rate
place profit s and that's
cool so we we changed all this i'm just
going to go through here and make sure
everything was changed
cool okay
so now that i did that which is it's
really not that big of a deal um
i just wanted to call it profit
estimation because that's what we're
going to do we're going to try to
calculate you know
our predictions profitability every time
it predicts so when it gets something
wrong
we'll try to penalize it when it gets it
right uh we'll gain some
revenue from from that from preventing a
customer from
leaving the business okay let's actually
go through this i want to okay
so with event calm this is checking the
event level so
when we put in our global options that
our event level is like first
it means that the first level of our
predicted class
will be used as the positive class um
that's why i kind of reversed it but i
could have always done the global option
i don't really like the global option
because it kind of mess with some things
okay so this is the actual meat and
potatoes of it
um so you can see profit estimation
vector
um this is the function that basically
does all of it um as you can see it's a
pretty
simple uh it's a pretty simple uh
function it's just saying okay we're
going to create this vector
and this is the actual logic for it so x
tab
this is just creating the confusion
matrix
between at the actual predicted and
actual values
this is obviously a classification
problem so we're going to deal with a
lot of confusion matrices
okay so call right here is just taking
the first event level as a positive so
that's saying like this is the positive
class
this is the negative class so what we
can see here
is with our true positive if it predicts
a positive and it's actually positive
it's a true positive so this is grabbing
the crosstab
of the true positive um frequency
and now we have a false negative so this
false negative is when it's produced
predicting a negative when actually it's
a positive
okay so now what we can do is just add
in our true negative
okay our true negative is when we
predict negative and it's actually a
negative
now what we have to do is just do a
false positive uh which is just saying
we predicted a positive when it should
have been
a negative right so this is prediction
in actual
so predicted positive actually a
positive true positive
uh predict a negative when it's actually
a positive false negative
predict a negative when it's a negative
three negative predict a positive
predict a positive when it's a negative
false positive
and now we have our actual um logic
right here
so in this case we have to do what we
have to do is basically estimate
what is the cost or what is the revenue
that we get
um from directly predicting that a
potential uh customer will potentially
churn or will churn
okay so when i think about this
we want to predict when a customer is
about to turn because that way we can
say like
if we're like an ecommerce site we can
send them a coupon and that way
you know we'll we'll save some money
right um this could be like a customer
lifetime value
uh it could just be like an annual
revenue or annual profit
but the main idea behind this is we want
to attribute some type of
uh of profit from this so i'm just going
to keep it simple and say okay we'll
gain a hundred dollars for that
okay so what happens if we have a false
negative
okay so that means if we predict we
predicted
that um this person wasn't going to turn
and they actually churned so this should
be a heavily penalized
value right so let's just say it's
okay if we said that this person wasn't
going to turn and they left the business
that's going to be highly penalized
right
if anything we could probably actually
reduce this because
we don't want to lose our existing
customers okay what's next for the true
negative
so we're just saying that this
customer's not going to turn and they
don't end up trending
so for this case you know you we could
say that we save some costs with like a
coupon or something like that so
we'll just say uh in all intents and
purposes which say
a true negative is worth about five
dollars
okay and then finally for a false
positive is when we say that
hey this guy's gonna churn and he
doesn't he doesn't actually end up
churning
uh you know we could have sent him some
you know uh
uh some goodies some coupons that he
might have used
but he wasn't actually gonna end up uh
churning so we might actually you know
subtract like i don't know
five dollars right on the on the uh
on the the turn so right there is our
actual model um
honestly uh this is very ad hoc and one
thing i would say is
you know this is something where you
know as a data scientist or data analyst
you you'd actually want to meet with
business people
and talk to business people whether it's
like uh you know like a a customer
person like a customer executive or a or
someone who runs really all the products
and stuff like that
or even like an accountant so you could
talk to an accountant and say you know
what's the cost of us keeping an
employee
what's the cost of us a losing employee
you know uh talk to marketing and say
like okay how can we
save or prevent a a person or customer
from
leaving the business what would it how
much it would cost on average
so stuff like that is something where
you would actually do a lot of business
stuff
you'd do a lot of meetings you know talk
to other people
and have them give you uh a better
estimate
but for this video which is definitely
going on
um uh you know it's a little out of the
scope of this video
is we're just estimating right here just
you know giving a kind of a
gut feeling i don't expect this to be
right i think it's pretty arbitrary we
actually might even change it
but that's basically it so now what
we're actually
going to do is this is the template for
it so it's saying
and we'll give it our function truth
estimate any remove
ohms or factor etc and then this is the
thing where it's actually
functionalizing into
an actual uh data frame so
that's all good and dandy okay
so one of the things that we can do um
is kind of enable a multi-class
classification
um in this case i really don't want to
do that for this video because it kind
of doesn't make any sense
um a customer is either a return or not
that's what the question is so
i'm just going to stick with it as a
generic binary variable
okay cool so right when i finished that
we actually got our actually boost rep
results so we were actually boost tune
i'm going to say collect metrics
in this case let's see here let's look
at let's just arrange
by the average so oops
so actually what i'm going to do is do
an autoplot
right and now we can see okay accuracy
definitely
takes a um when we're when we're doing
um we're
you know uh increasing our tree depth
and then starting to
increase once we make our depth even
deeper
um what i'm seeing is like okay right
here is a case of overfitting
we can see our meanwhile gloss is
increasing which is bad and then we can
see how
our roc auc score drops and kind of kind
of goes around but that could also be an
indication overfitting
especially when we see our mean log loss
is increasing what i'm thinking right
here is
you know one tree i believe at 500 trees
so a very simple model let's actually do
some sandy check so
um actually boost uh tune and then say
collect a show best we'll say accuracy
right 500 trees one 74 accuracy
i'm good with that cool
yep okay so let's actually create our
final model so
final uh model
will create a work well
add model which will be actually boost
model
add recipe which is our tidy recipe
and then we'll say finalize oops
model and right here what i'm going to
do is i'm going to do a select
one to two and then i slice one which
i'll extract oops
maybe i can do go uh
and then say
and equals one there
and we'll finalize a model like that
i actually wanna probably should show
what those parameters are right there so
okay um
oh
oh xgboos tune is finalize
workflow cool so we have our final model
and with our final model right
we can do our final fit or we'll say uh
uh eva uh eval df which will be our
last fit final model and give it our
tidy split
right and then with our eval df
we can say i collect uh we can say first
collect metrics to see how our
our scores going so right now we have
pretty good actually that actually is
the same thing
it's a little bit higher than our um our
in sample accuracy
and we have a decent amount a decently
high uh rocio c score
right we can also do you know yeah
uh we can collect our predictions so
collect
predictions then we can do like maybe a
confusion matrix so truth equals uh
turn estimate equals
dot pred
class right so we're pretty good when we
predict 300
uh when we predic a customer return
um 306 out of 306
plus 278 when we pre
predict that a customer will turn we're
about 50 chance right
um however out of all of the
um actual churned customers
um we actually predicted about 82
percent of them so
um are our models a little um trigger
happy
with uh predicting that someone will
churn but um i think in businesses we
might see that that's actually fine
uh because uh let's actually calculate
our
um our our metric right here
so right now oops we have our
metric which i believe is called
like predictions and then i think we
need to say profit
estimation and we say truth is equal to
churn
estimate is equal to dot prod
uh class right and our estimated profit
is twenty three thousand two and twenty
dollars
that's great right okay i was like okay
this model you know i just
i just made this model in 24 minutes and
uh we have a pr we can estimate this
value of this model uh assuming it's
gonna work for about twenty three
thousand dollars
it's probably way less than that because
generally models in the wild perform
uh a little bit worse actually a lot of
it a lot worse
um but that's a good estimation right
there so
one of the things that we can do to
improve it is since we have this
this um you know we have these values as
true positive false negatives
right now on default it just uses when
we our model predicts the probability of
50
as a churn but realistically um
with our actual you know metric you know
we might want to actually lower that
threshold so we can
predict more often that someone will
turn or maybe even predict a little bit
less
that is something where the actual um
probably probably package
could um help a lot um while i was
workshopping this video
um i thought probably the probability uh
probably package
would be great with a threshold proof
where we could basically assign it
across a list of probabilities
and they could basically show that
metric when we have that threshold
however they don't actually offer custom
metrics
um yet they are there i saw that there
was a pull request for it but
right now currently they do not offer uh
custom metrics so what we're actually
gonna have to do
is create a function for this and just
do it ourselves
right so that's fine uh what we can do
is select
the dot pred yes and also
churn well what we're going to say is
profit
max df okay
so with our profit max tf what we can do
now
is let's just actually figure out how we
would do this so first let's actually
say
um our default uh prediction is 50
or above so we'll just say red is equal
to if
else dot pred yes is greater than equal
to
0.5 and it's
a yes else then it's a no
all right um what then what we can do
now is just count
them out so count churn and pred
and now what we can also do is just kind
of create our
um uh we can also
uh what sorry about what we can also do
now is then just say our
price oh what is it what they call it
profit s so we can now do our profit
estimation
and we can say okay our truth is equal
to churn
and our estimate is equal to pred um
what i'm going to have to do is also say
pred is equal to as that
factor um pred right
so one of the problems is there's a
problem with the levels um
in this case we can say like okay well
pred is equal to um
uh factor view level and we'll just say
like pred and then
um no was it after uh yes
right or is it yes after no so yes it's
after
no and i'll calculate it right and we we
kind of have a sanity check where it's
like yeah okay 50
50 yeah and then we can say okay what
about point eighty percent
right we can see our profit is going
down or point one percent
so this is a pretty cool thing right
here we can just
tweak this formula right here so let's
just say max
maximize um profit
so function give it a prob put this in
there
l will even pluck dot estimate right dot
what is that oh yeah what
pluck and we'll say plug three
right so we can just throw this thing in
here
um and then change this to prop
right and now what we can do now is we
can create a table
um we can say our prob is equal to seek
0.0121
actual point was 8.99 and we'll say
change it by
one all right so we have our prob uh our
little table of probabilities
then we say profit is equal to map abl
prop rob and then maximize
profit and then we can see
that we come into this problem where it
still gives me on this function error
with where the levels aren't
um equivalent that's because sometimes
it'll just say like oh we're always just
going to predict yes
so that way the levels are are only it's
only a single level
um i definitely think you can probably
manually re i recode the levels
but i think we can actually create a
better function
so instead of just doing that one of the
things i would think
is useful is when we have those actual
profit values so like
um revenue and cost values um it'd be
kind of nice to have that as an actual
like
you know um uh
in the function so we can actually have
someone tweak it right you can put this
in a shiny dashboard
and then show the model out um as like a
diagnostic and say okay
tweak with the true positive false
positive values uh and let's see which
which profit we can do
or we could even do like kind of like a
bayesian approach right and say like
okay like we're gonna estimate that you
know our true positive
revenues is is in this distribution or
something like that right
on a yearly or quarterly basis and we
can kind of get some more confidence
intervals
um i'm saying all of this basically to
say that we can just
you know do it manually and be fine with
it so
with a profit max df we just say count
pred
and turn oops and we'll say
0.5 for right now
and then we just do a case statement so
we'll say mutate oops
um yeah so we'll say mutate
um uh type
we'll say mutate and we'll say uh
uh what's here uh we'll say uh profit is
equal to
ace when so when pred is equal to
uh we'll should say yes and turn
is equal to yes and that means it's a
true positive so it's going to be
multiplied times our true positive
times n else let's do our
false positive so our pred is equal to
yes
and our turn is equal to no and it's a
false positive times the amount of
samples that we
falsely predicted right now we can do
our pred is equal to
no and then our turn is equal to
no which is a true negative
times the total amount of true niggles
we actually predicted
and then finally we can do our false
negative which is false negative times
n right
we can do that put that in there
and then we can just say summarize and
then profit is equal to
sum profit block
one right
um one of the things that we can also do
i'm going to go back up here
and kind of just like use these as our
default values so we'll say like uh
and then so f2 tp is equal to
90 fp is equal to um
minus 100 true negative
is equal to 5 uh
false negative is equal to minus 100 i'm
sorry about that so true positive
is 90. false positive is minus
five uh true negative is plus five
then false negative is minus one hundred
uh and then i also have to change that
to
problem so let's actually do this
again right
that pred is equal to
let's see here what's going on here well
i'm going to input profit
oh that first and then let's actually
test test this profit
um function out so prob 0.5
um pred rob
profit you take profit
fps
must be a two-sided formula oh
sorry about that uh summarize and then
profit is equal to sum profit
okay so now that's our profit and what
we can also do is we plug this
right and now what we can do
is we can actually simulate all the
profits and we can do like you know a
profit curve so ggplot
aes x equals prob y equals profit
uh and just to a gm point
plus gm line lvu and i'll say
also do a uh um
profit a color which is equals if else
profit is less than equal to zero then
it's um
loss else profit
right so then we can just say uh yeah
like a yes
color all right so
you can see right here this is our
probability as you can see once we um
and then what
uh dm
h line y intercept is zero on type is
equal to
right so now we can see our profit cut
off where you know we can really
maximize our profit up here
in fact what i can actually do is just
say uh
[Music]
um
i i'll worry about that so sorry about
that
um so yeah so right now we have our
profit curve
um showing you know how powerful our
model is and we can all see our cutoff
for that um i'm actually going to look
at that
so if we actually look at our
um curve our cutoff means to say arrange
by descending order
and profit and we can see that
we actually have our probability cut off
of like .17
so a very highly trigger happy
model but obviously we can uh we can
obviously adjust how trigger happy this
model gets with
changing of uh our function right here
right so we can just say you know
instead of our map dvl we
say you know what if we say a true
negative is equal to like zero
right it kills even higher um
so stuff like that right um it's nothing
too crazy but
um it is actually pretty useful right um
so definitely custom metrics is going to
be a pretty cool
um useful tool especially when you're in
a setting that you know
actually has some business applications
or um you need to share it to
actual stakeholders so i'm just going to
say applied
business so yeah um i definitely think
that um using custom metrics creating
your own
especially with like profitability um is
a pretty useful thing to have
and um i'm sure uh you know your
managers will love it you know
directors will love it so doing stuff
like this
definitely has applications in your data
science framework
we don't have to worry we don't have to
always speak in like roc
auc scores you know sometimes it's
better just speaking dollars
so yeah i think this is a pretty good
video um with that being said i'll see
you guys next week and
tidy on